liebe dolores ich hatte auch das cello
klavier spielen sehen ich glaube er ist
ein genie n sie ich möchte keine
fettflecken auf meiner decke ruhig war
keine fettflecken auf einer decke
es fällt mir schwer etwas positives über
green book zu sagen der jetzt für fünf
oscars nominiert wurde
wie ich finde völlig mysteriöserweise er
spielt in den in den 60er jahren frühen
60er jahre 1962 erzählt die geschichte
eines chauffeurs eines kleines italo
amerikaners der in allerhöchster not
einen job den job des chauffeurs eines
schwarzen pianisten annimmt david
blatter angerufen entdeckte brocken
fahrer interessiert ich bin kein
mediziner
ich bin musiker ich gehe heute auf
konzertreise in den tiefen süden
warum haben sie sonst noch erfahrungen
wie gordon sind spielt diesen chauffeur
und er hat alles getan um dabei so
auszusehen wie tony soprano und das
allein finde ich eigentlich schon ganz
schrecklich weist so hat geworden und er
spricht genau wie james kann dafür
hamburg.de stelle falsche methode also
wie ein mafioso der er möglicherweise
auch ist und so darf er natürlich in new
york aussprechen wo das ganze losgeht
im süden kommt das dann nicht mehr so
gut
wir werden bei den vermögendsten leuten
dieses landes verkehr ihre
ausdrucksweise könnte etwas stift
vertragen
warum gehen sie mir so auf den sack weil
sie es besser können
er selber ist auch in rassismus langen
eigentlich sagen
fried chicken so was habe ich noch nie
in meinem leben gegessen er einst liebte
ihre meinung über mich jetzt wirklich
spezifisch tonya oder gut für so ein
prachtexemplar macht er dann doch eine
ausnahme und setzt sich für ihn ein
gewalt sieht nie gewinnt kann man nur
mit würde
und jetzt eine eigene leute nicht du
bist der bild schaut gibt es konzerte
für die reichen wenn ich nicht schwarz
genug bin und ich weiß gedruckt
das green book des titels ist ein buch
in dem die herbergen unterkünfte motels
stehen die in den schwarzen abend
parkplatz nicht sofort erschließen
sondern ihm unter umständen ein zimmer
geben
jeder kann sich anhören wie beethoven
aber die musik die du machst
[Musik]
kannst nur du allein
dieser film wettbewerben als feel good
movie wo ich mich frage was im
amerikanischen süden jener jahre für
einen schwarzen unterwegs oder der auf
das greenback angewiesen wäre nun
irgendwie viel gut sein könnte
viel wird es also dass es sich diese
freundschaft entwickelt mit diesem
rassisten
ich finde es vollständig lächerlich von
anfang bis zum ende
und ob es nun wahr ist oder nicht
interessiert mich gar nicht ich werde so
wie es im film aussieht das ist gelogen
was machst du dann schreiben darf ich
liebe das ist manchmal erinnerst du mich
an ein haus ganz schön armselig toni
schreibt über das kann dir getrennt zu
sein bringt mich fast um den verstand
ich an dich zu verleben war für mich die
einfachste sache der welt
er ist kuss an die kinder das ist wie
eine kuhglocke am ende von
schostakowitsch siebter ist es gut das
ist perfekt
was machen wir mit den knochen ganz
einfach
[Musik]
neben auftritten die eichhörnchen libyen
auf